じゃあ一さんそうです
っていうのも
この部屋ですよ
じゃあはじめ写像せっていうのはあっ
上で最後となります昔から見てる人ならわかると思うんですけど
今日までん
ほとんどこの家で
僕は
youtube に動画を出すというのを初めて行きましたねこの部屋にはもうを取る
ことないんで
部屋でんで引き払って
ここいつも他の部屋もあるんですけどたいてい1席なんで
またここに戻ってくることはないと思います壁全部付いてるし
鍵も4回亡くしたんですけど
全部ちゃんと
国家ような来てくれて
影のおじさんにも顔を覚えてもないあ
持ってったよ
やっぱりです本当に一人暮らしする人絶対であっつのほうがいいですよ
ちょっとだけ昔の動画でも見ながら
部屋と分かりしましょう
もどって来ることないんだよああ
part 2
ran
えっ
行くああ
プレ
プランパー2
to do おっ
うわぁ
th
ぷっん
単焦点レンズって何ですか博士簡単に言えばズームやって来ないプロレンズのこと
ファイター
5どうせまみ
ええええええ
スクールに全然入れたいと思います
あっ
あれいや塁側で勉強にゃーん
薄いできねーっ
ああああああ
うん4
cha
4 wd ん
ぬーんうそ
えって白 beep 1回
ん
皆さんこんにちはう
携帯などシッター瑞絵
ああああああ
みたいな
分後に別な形だけ浮いでしょ
おおーー
よかったん
いっっ
ぷっ
匂いもすごい嫌な気分になるんちら高かっ
ううん違う
じゃあもう完全にシーローだねこれは
サーブチョチョチョンっ
ポッポ良いもしかもしかっん
やばいだろ
me
恋はないよ
潰れてくれ
持っています
おっ
母
今ますちゃっちゃーさんちゃん
コッターじゃんちゃんじゃじゃじゃ
多分4 b ぐらいかなぁ
ドレッサーの初恋ってどんなんだったんですかあああ
わー
いきます
ん
今後1回富山に帰ってしばらくですよ
大麻にいってもちょっとバタバタして
そんな動画出せないと思うんで日本まだ日本が3本出ない
日本で動画出す予定なんでよろしくお願いしますよ
よろしくお願います
続きで
始めたちは
シーズン2に入るというわけでイギリス編が始まるんで
またねー
体張るとか
おもしろ動画と方はあ
人たち違う
ねまた行こうと思います以上
箸での最後の動画でした
お願いします
じゃんっ
goo
me
いこが
持っています